given all of this trauma that you go
through
why would you choose to go back and see
this Tyrant of a father
for one last time it was the only way
for me to move forward
so like a lot of times
if your back is hurting it may not be
your back
it may be something else in your bias
making your back hurt
for me
I'm like man why can't I get past this
hurdle
it's like I said I'm always examining
myself every day
what is it what is it
well there's only one thing you haven't
examined yet and it's going back to the
Beast going back to the demon so when I
went back to him I realized that that
was the unsolved mystery
was I had to look that man the eye one
more time
like how I studied the that Navy SEAL
talking lion
I got it from this part right here in
the book
I went and I didn't see him anymore as
this Beast
I started doing research on him found
out that his dad used to beat him really
bad so my his dad
would put him in front of a furnace
open the furnace up with the Flames
coming out
and put them right in front of it
having bare butt naked
and he would whip the [__] out of him
and the whole idea of that is if you
move you're gonna get burned
so stay right here and take your beating
so what happened with him
those demons from his father went to my
father
and he tried to transfer him over to me
I had to understand who my father was
understand where he came from understand
why were you so brutal to us
I got my answers
took those answers it made myself better
from the answers about him
and so that's why it was necessary for
me to go back not I was looking for an
apology
so then maybe I could just go be a loser
and understand that you [__] me up why
would the apology make you a loser
it would make no it would make me feel
Vindicated Justified yes like man you
you did this to me
I can go be a loser now my failings are
okay this okay yep because you did this
so I was looking for that and when I
went there I I realized because this
voice and he was saying it's not your
dad's fault
and I'm like ah man because his voice
over here always said it's your dad's
fault this other voice started tuning in
was loud started getting louder the more
I drove to Buffalo was saying
you get to face a lot of [__] young man
you got a long journey ahead of you
because you're gonna find out that while
your dad did a lot of [__] to you
you're gonna have to [__] make it on
your own
and the voice got louder and louder and
louder and by time I got to that door
and by time I was leaving that house
instead of me feeling sorry for myself
I started to doing live autopsy
to a lot of people
when you die
they figure out why you died they figure
out how you died
in the autopsy
but we never do a live autopsy to figure
out why we're dying while we are alive
and I was dying I was living every day
but I was really dead
and so I figured it out and once I
figured it out I was able to
reborn I was able to be reborn
what we see is this pattern of
generational trauma your grandfather to
your father your father to you father to
son just being passed on passed on
passed on
is this part of your mission to be a
circuit breaker to be a dam to stop this
Trauma from moving forward into the Next
Generation 100 but with people I'm
trying to build people up
I'm trying to armor their mind I'm
trying to get them the belief because
this world we live in is tough
it's tough it will beat you down the
world and the life that we live in is
the ultimate competitor it will try to
take you out it will it will find your
weakness
and it will [__] just Hammer you it's
like a personal cause a hundred percent
so if I can help you
build belief build confidence to the
point where
nothing can hurt you because you know
exactly who you are you've faced your
demons
you've you've been able to go on an
audiobook in your mind maybe you didn't
write a book but in your mind you were
able to hear all your past traumas
you're able to listen to them
you're able to [__] say okay now I
can now talk to people about what I went
through I'm no longer embarrassed I'm no
longer ashamed being ashamed is one of
the biggest things that kill people
nowadays in their minds kill them from
moving forward I'm ashamed of myself
don't ever be ashamed of anything you've
done in your life face it fix it make it
better
we are humans
but then again if you always think that
we're humans
you will always just be a human and
always make the same [__] mistakes
you must take this knowledge that you
learned from all this [__] is knowledge
so I'm just trying to give people that
strength to go in the archives of your
life
because
while you're probably [__] up is
probably something happened to you in
your life go through the archives dig it
up
study it
and then use it for yourself that's
that's the main purpose for me right now
have you considered what you would be
like as a father
yeah I actually have a daughter right
now
yeah no way I didn't know yeah
I have a daughter right now but that
being said
I'm an open honest person
when you meet people at a young age so I
had a kid at a young age when I was in
the worst possible place in my life so
when you're in a bad place
you're not going to meet a Kish
you're going to meet a person that's
very similar to who you are at that time
and then you bring a child into this
world and as you start to move up in
this world and get better and you
realize I need to get better
you try to pull that person along with
you
a lot of times they don't want to come
where you're going
and it creates a bad environment
so
that's what that is right now this
episode is brought to you by element
element is a tasty electrolyte drink mix
with everything that you need and
nothing that you don't I've replaced my
morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guiding
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
slash modern wisdom thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Goggins then press here for the
full episode in all of its glory and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]